hello welcome to hey [ __ ] we are the
[ __ ] and all the [ __ ] in one place
we've only done a few episodes like this
you're in luck let's take some roll call
just reminded geo bones Nikki mm-hmm
Oh teacher I'm here to Jeana Jessup jess
is here I started I wasn't gonna let her
out just yet but Jess we're talking
about foreplay come out to foreplay you
by the way forward to foreskin I mean
I'm not against it yeah I'm not against
it either Gio I am clearly I'm not
either
yeah they don't discriminate Oh
forewarning hottes we're in a funky mood
yeah this is like our last episode of
the dead lesotho today and we had a lot
and we've been filming a lot houki yeah
losing their mind so I think it's
because there's so much estrogen and
we're all synched up after that one God
if I start tomorrow I'm laying all of
you there's no way I'm starting if you
do I just finished so we're good I
finished lost buted I mean that's
[ __ ] crazy I just found out about
ovulation and I was like wait why are
you [ __ ] me I didn't know I want to
keep it I did know but I'm just trying
to pretend here yeah they don't feel
left now it's my genuine reaction I just
found out yeah so I had this guys I have
this app you know I have this app and
it's for periods and natural cycles
that's what I use I'm like that's one
free advertisement dog oh yeah um what
maybe there was a app that I use and
like it you're supposed to track your
period and it tells you when it's safe
to kind of like have sex that you most
likely be taking right matter Ivan de
I'm not that far I just found out about
ovulation niggy
yeah
I should all be experienced so the
calendar shows when your periods about
to start or when it's currently
happening and then there was this green
line and I was like what is this and I
clicked on it and it was like you're
ovulating you may experience nausea
headaches another cement happens when
you ovulate that you're letting your
pregnant girlfriend when your app that's
when you got sweat well I'm definitely
not pregnant so but yeah it's dude it
says okay let me teach you guys about
ovulation because I just read about all
of this last month you may experience
headaches and nausea yeah some people
get it okay you're taking a sexy topic
and turning at real science we're
talking about foreplay today have
foreplay when she's ovulating I just
want to throw it in there that when
Tiffany and her eggs are releasing you
can feel it ya know so my what is this
right my right ovary protrudes I can
feel my ovary yeah yeah I felt her
ovaries maybe one day feel it right now
Nikki maybe Casey can feel her ovaries
but from the inside
oh he does how does she let him do that
with foreplay first first let's talk
about because I feel like let's let's
talk about what foreplay is to everybody
here because I feel like people's
definitions of it are different and
varied and I also feel like they've
changed over the course of you know age
like I feel like my definition has
gotten different well yeah if I got
punch in the face that's foreplay for me
thank you okay fine if you [ __ ] are
gonna be shy I'll talk about it yes so
my definition of foreplay is everything
before the penetration so talk to me
dirty touch me don't touch me directly
like like on it
oh yes tease me like I'm a citrus [ __ ]
were you kind of like get all bendy I do
but I would I recall seeing them all
bendy
you could get there but like really the
whole basis behind it is doing
everything but touching yeah so that
builds up that [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
out of me and I'm like what to do yeah
dude that totally sounds up my alley for
me it's a like kissing my neck that
that's me is like a dream like hot spot
yeah my house box what warms the oven
mm-hmm she's like carbonation 20% of
those my guess is this is the most
unsexy six top of go I just want to say
what what's one thing that guys do
during foreplay that I don't like is
that okay to say yes yeah absolutely
yeah
I was thinking about this earlier cuz I
know we kind of talked about what maybe
we wanted to speak on today so in the
car I was thinking and I was like okay
so we're I'm gonna have plenty of
positive stories what's one thing I
don't like and I remember it turns me
off every single time when I'm like kind
of making out with a like a new guy I'm
like kind of like maybe it's a new
relationship or something and then they
start trying to finger me like over my
pants or like over like over my clothes
or something or maybe they'll try to go
inside but then they don't know where
the [ __ ] is
around you if you can't find my [ __ ]
[ __ ] with your fingers I'm way turned
off now like just before you go on that
right there's like rubbing my [ __ ]
pelvic bone all over my right side of my
lip and I'm like play it safe and make
big movements I will say on Palm Beach
yeah no don't do that
oh hey away from and just stay like
around the hip area just like kind of
hold me you're like Nokia what turn me
on if he's rubbing me over my pants but
if he is owns in and he can't find it
turn off yeah but and then also if he's
looking at you all sexy like he's like
yeah you [ __ ] like this and you're
like dude my my foreplay thing is like a
little bit of your know and a little bit
of your yes my thing is like I dated
this guy once and like we'd be making
out for like 30 seconds and then he
would immediately just put his hand on
my vagina and just like I mean he would
just like start and I mean whatever he
was doing I didn't [ __ ] like it yeah
and I'm like it's the same thing and
what you said like yo guys like rub
around the thighs rub around the butt or
something just like rub everywhere just
leave it alone so this is the vagina
hopefully you're watching on YouTube
dude just like rub like the thigh look
you know here's the goal no here's the
objective it's you you want to make the
girl think about you touching it yeah oh
yeah yeah like that we can't wait for it
to actually happen like dude you could
literally go in a hole like explore like
where's the clitoris her 20 minutes and
I'd be like oh he's gonna find it soon
like dude yeah like that's the reaction
you want yeah dude yeah mine isn't even
like the clitoris like if you rub next
to my boob but like not my boob yet and
like you you're like a brown my stomach
yeah under the boob and you're like from
the side of it and you haven't touched
it yet I just want you to grow my
[ __ ] tits and like look lick my
nipple like it'd be kind of boring like
they're like like wax on wax off for 20
minutes but we're like in our head
and crazy I'm thinking about like I
don't like them to try to zero in right
away like we make out and they're like
oh where's the [ __ ] clue like also
the one thing on this podcast we have
all unanimously agrees about how women
in general tend to be more sensual
creatures like we get way turned on by
sensual stuff so - Gina and then write
the face I need you to take the vacuum
and just beat me with it but guys are
visual so like they get turned on
immediately with visual things they
don't necessarily need to be touched to
get turned off right so it Bartz a
mixture of both I think they need to get
an engine immediately that's why they go
immediately for like the trigger spots
for women cuz that's what they want they
immediately took their already turned on
yeah yeah so they're already turned on
visually and they want you to touch it
now yeah so women tend to need more
sensual stuff to get in like that oh
yeah I had so many like guys that would
tell me like I just really like it when
you look like you're having the greatest
time like I want to see you enjoying it
I like porn mm-hmm oh that's interesting
Steve likes it when I cry and pretend I
hate it it's consensual
yeah I think it's you talk to your
partner first wait yes
like I'll be like ooh you like that he's
like pretend you hate it I'm like
[ __ ] sexy if you're like yeah like
your dick is so [ __ ] bad like they're
probably like okay they're like yeah
abuse me he's like slap your face with
it yeah I like that so we're at this for
the phase were there they're rubbing
they're touching what isn't it let's
back it up for a second because I think
it's so important for people to know
that this is an important part of sex
yeah for both parties because I didn't
think it was important no before I
thought it was all about let's get to
the sex I don't need that foreplay stuff
yeah but a lot of girls also are the
misconception for guys come in with her
sex should last an hour where in reality
the foreplay is like 30 minutes and
maybe the real sex is like 1520 nights I
dated a guy who was not really into
foreplay like it was just like okay kind
of work okay I'd be into it
yeah he he wasn't like super into it it
was more like the only way he can get up
is if I suck his dick first and that was
the only foreplay that I got that went
the only four yeah
and then we'd [ __ ] and I'm just like and
then after a while is like it's this is
so routine and I had to constantly do
this would he go down on you during
foreplay um every once in a while you
know which is like and then I was just
like when he did go down on me it was
great it was bomb right but then like
after a while I got so 14 I'm like this
is so [ __ ] lame like I can't I can't
deal with this if this is the only four
if you're not beating the [ __ ] out of me
like if I'm not getting fist in the bow
this is a case by case or like if you're
not catering to what I like and what I'm
into yeah more and all you want just
hate let's just say my dick and then
let's have sex you ever had
did you guys ever have a conversation or
what yeah he was just like I don't know
like because he was such like a
Christian boy kind of you know sounds
very Christian yeah they need to be
trained yeah exactly but like at this
point he was like 30-something years old
already he's online so it was like kind
of a can't teach an old dog new tricks
yeah yeah yeah I cannot have the sex
that's a shame mm-hmm yeah because I
feel like it foreplay is for the benefit
of both parties it's the way that you
get each other worked up so that like
Bose was saying when you actually do
have sex it's not supposed to last an
hour it's like you're already like both
they're ready to the N last an hour
though I don't like long me but just may
prefer it do you prefer that just I
really prefer sexually foreplay to last
an hour and sex to last an hour
Wow like a whole thing happen oh yeah
everybody can we get your sex to
foreplay breakdowns
yeah yeah ratio lets you know break it
down Jess I can't tell time when I'm in
it that's like I can't I can't tell how
long it's probably only like ten minutes
on the clock for hand they look at it
after I'll ever have mm-hmm Sophie it's
like
Oh Oh for me so I'll be asking ya what
happens in that hour of foreplay so
there's just a lot of it's just very
like slow like you know that's [ __ ]
song and it's so lame but like your body
is a wonderland like taking the time
like have your own guy widest person
ever made this conversation okay have
you ever had a guy just like kind of
just like appreciate yes yes time and
like he'll just speak in Gio's lovely so
I have it may not necessarily have to be
an hour but like the making out hard and
then like to just like yeah you're
talking about just like touching around
around everything and like maybe 30
minutes of episode 1 yeah so first sex
sometimes I like that it's just really
fast but I'm probably not going to have
an orgasm from that that's just like
that yeah I don't care
right or whatever like just to get it
over with but for like an hour-long
sexual experience like it's probably one
of the best things that you'll ever
experience in your life and it doesn't
happen all the time it only happens with
people that you really really connect
with sexually so it's hard to find
someone that can actually have good sex
for an hour yeah so that's probably why
a lot of women are like what an hour
exactly 15 minutes is already [ __ ]
enough you know what I mean but that's
because you haven't had that kind of
sexual experience so once you do I think
a lot of times you will prefer the
longer more kind of tantric sex I like
taking a lot longer Mitch she said an
hour of foreplay in an hour you can't
I mean I'm taught yeah I first got
together we would have that like like
foreplay for an hour sex for an hour
sometimes an hour and a half like it was
a lot like that's why we got together
was because we had that sex and yeah
that's that good [ __ ] yeah that's a good
yeah I know what I'm gonna experience it
at least once in your life yeah Gina
what's your
what's your ideal ratio so I have two
packages there's like a regular one in
the Nexus yes so that's like the deluxe
Express package so the deluxe one it's
like okay so here's the thing I don't
really I don't know it's weird I don't
really give a [ __ ] if I come or not okay
anyway yeah I don't really give a [ __ ] I
don't need to orgasm like even after I'm
like I don't need you know if I'm
masturbating fine I can make myself come
yeah if we're having sex
yeah I don't need to orgasm like an ATM
because I don't cuz I get off on hit me
two arrows so much better with me to my
love you're not alone like I love like I
would rather like come oncome I wanna
see you go home you know so um the
deluxe package is if I get to orgasm
like yeah that's for a while you know
because like that takes a little bit
more time I'm all about it whatever the
Express package if you're traveling
you're short on time so this is actually
what I prefer most of the time mmm I
don't like the whole like slow build-up
and then the whatever I'm like a burst
of energy and you know just get in there
do some dirty [ __ ] bang you come I'm
good I'm happy and then we take like a
rest and we can do it again so it's just
like Express package after Express
package okay multiple more play on that
or some foreplay yeah what's your idea
of far away and okay yeah just really
quick for like a minute or like yeah
oh yeah so like I like I like the burst
of energy and the just like the crazy
and the spontaneous whatever and then
like I like that multiple times so we'll
do that take a break and then do that
again like the longer like I've had a
guy who was just like I'm gonna [ __ ] you
too the Sun comes off [ __ ] off yeah
trying to drag it out dragging it out
yeah yeah because because he was good in
bed but the thing what I like is when
the orgasm so he would always keep on
edging himself
oh stop my rhythm too cuz we're all in
it and then he's like slows it down to
nothing and then we lay there for a
second yeah what'd I tell Bart to do in
that situation
yeah exactly so what do you do is like
he'd stop and they were just like let's
lay here for a second I'm just like
boring on a Casper oh god I have a
Casper and it is amazing it is my
favorite mattress I have ever had in my
life and I'm not exaggerating at all
so I upgraded to a king-size bed me and
so I needed king-size mattress and we
got Casper and I used to have to have a
pillow top on top of like a memory foam
pillow top this is like the most
comfortable sleep I've ever had without
any sort of topper or anything like that
and I think it's because it's designed
by humans for humans so Casper products
are cleverly they cleverly designed to
mimic human curves providing support and
comfort for all kinds of bodies I have
scoliosis I have a lot of back pain and
problems and this bed is the most
comfortable bed like when I wake up I
don't feel sore all over like I come
over
yeah can we have a sleep well Lots in
there now Nikki's king-sized cancer just
don't sleep in the wet spot so breathe
the whole design about my face and
regulate your body temperature
throughout the night so if you had some
you know activity that made you censor
yourself boys it's a read it's an ad
read and sorry myself a little bit okay
sorry but Casper also offers a wide
array of other products like pillows and
sheets to ensure an overall better sleep
experience it's convenient
they got affordable prices because
Casper cuts out the middleman and sells
directly to you and it's also free
shipping and returns in the US and
Canada so if you bought it because you
heard me talk about it and then you're
like you know what Nikki you're full of
[ __ ] this isn't good you can return it
but I doubt you'll ever say that because
it is by far the best mattress I've ever
had also please don't return it with wet
spots on it yeah don't do that you can
be sure your purchase with Casper is a
100 night risk-free sleep on it trials
you can actually sleep on it figure out
if you like it you get a hundred nights
to figure it out that's like a third of
a year yeah you can also get a hundred
dollars towards select mattresses by
visiting Casper comm slash hey girl
and using hey girl at checkout terms and
conditions apply but that's H ey GI RL
that's $100 towards select mattresses at
Casper calm slash hey girl and just use
the code hey girl yeah hey girl do you
know what else really affects your
sleeping what Jia your actual weight
I've noticed when I noticed when I was
pregnant I was like I think 40 pounds
overweight and I had the worst time
sleeping yes and I've also heard that
from bar the heavier he got like he had
sleep apnea it was just very
uncomfortable this joints hurt so I want
to introduce our next bouncer Noom they
are a healthy habit weight loss app and
I absolutely love it I love the approach
that they take when it comes to weight
loss it's not about like counting
numbers only and then just kind of
excluding everything else or just
focusing on like you know I want my body
to look this way and they're like okay
well here you go and giving you some
generic stuff they really start from
within psychological aspects yes yeah
and I love that because I feel like
that's with what the recipe for success
is when you understand what's going on
in your mind then you can start changing
habits from bad to good and then you can
continue on without having to focus on
like like a specific guide or a tracker
or any of that cuz like you can just
understand it and then just do it on
your own I also think everyone knows the
feeling of losing a bunch of weight and
then gaining it all back yeah so numa's
that habit changing solution that helps
users that helps oh that helps users
learn to develop a new relationship with
food through personalized courses which
I absolutely love one of the biggest and
most accurate food database let see
track meal habits visualize portion
sizes and see calorie density at a
glance all the stuff they should have
taught you about like when you were
growing up but you never get to learn
this and then you get a dedicated person
that checks in with you via email
they're like hey how's everything going
to have any questions I absolutely love
you because you never feel alone you're
never like overwhelmed like what the
hell am I doing here so for all of you
guys right now listening sign up for
your trial today at noon that's n oo
m.com slash b tch visit Noom comm slash
b tch to start your trial today one more
time that's Noom calm b tch all right
and back to foreplay oh right my turn
yeah I think was a good regional Express
package yeah but yeah so that's
basically what I am I have my I rather
prefer shorter sex hmm-hmm nice I think
that means you don't really like sex oh
no I love to [ __ ] I do I really do it's
just that after a while I'm like I just
want to see you come like that's my
thing like you're holding this from me
and I want it I totally agree with Gina
and I am I get off way more once there
they're coming or like when I see the
pleasure and them that's what gives me
their common yeah so I recount just the
same as Gina like I don't need to come
like I'm pretty good is it the seeing
the pleasure in them or do you actually
feel a physical pleasure cuz right when
they're about to come I like the dick
throb and that
kind of like makes me orgasm a little
bit like I'm about it orgasm during sex
are cuz of did yeah it's visual visual
like I just have like a more type of
satisfaction that doesn't need to be
necessarily physically satisfied mmm
interesting I'm just fully satisfied and
it's pretty cool because recently case
and I have just we've been talking more
about our sex life even though we have
in the past but we were in a way worse
space back then but now that we're in a
better space and we've been more open
about what we like what we don't like
and like better communication now that
he knows like hey it's cool that
pressures off you don't need to make me
[ __ ] like he's just like hell yeah so
we've been having some bomb-ass be good
now it's just like no and on also with
the whole foreplay thing because we
talked about what really turns us on for
each other and so when we're able to
provide that for each other and we're
able to get there faster to the actual
like sex part once we're there then it's
like so much more connected and like hot
and it's just like yeah I get off like
so what we got foreplay okay so for me
you for me it's definitely I'm hanging
on your neck it's the kissing the neck
but also like when we make out it's not
like that that like quick like throwaway
kissing it's more like the deep
connected like the tongue and the lips
are all in it kind of thing where it's
not just like oh yeah just telling a
story exactly like you feel what you're
feeling you you got it yeah so then it's
that and then it moves on to like
recently it's been really really hot
it's like he he'll like try to undress
me but like really he's teasing himself
by oh that's very happy for you but I
also see my oldest like my brother and
I'm like this white little thing okay
I'll tell you it's some other guy from
my past
hey see don't know but yeah I don't know
like that that's the beginning of it
right so then it just moves on to like
oral for each other but sometimes I go
just be me on him or him on me and then
like we start don't have to do both yeah
yeah it's too like a systemic rocky yeah
so then now has just been cuz in the
past one of the issues that I had was
that again like apparently this is like
a really common thing with males where
they feel like they need to they feel
the pressures of needing to satisfy the
woman so they're not able to fully find
their pleasure in sex because of that
reason so now that that's kind of out
the door in our relationship he's been
able oh so the past problem was that we
couldn't ever advance to the next step
like it we always got stuck like making
out forever and I'm just like okay let's
go let's let's do the next thing again
like it was just like really like there
was just like all these like speed bumps
that we couldn't get past but now that
those aren't there and now we're able to
be like because he's starting to be a
little bit more selfish which helps yeah
because he's finding his pleasure which
pleasures me and then me pleasuring him
like he was exactly sure it's exactly
there was just too much pressure and I
think that that's probably him that has
been the case with my past relationships
because I always felt like I got hat I
have had good sex but not like amazing
sex and I think it was always because
this the guys always have this pressure
within themselves of like oh is she good
is she good without even thinking about
if they're having it that's nice like
that you were dating guys like that I
guess so but you know what it does
there is like a fine line because I have
dated a guy before where it's like I
just felt like a [ __ ] pocket [ __ ]
like it right not fuel any sort of
connection and and just felt like I was
being used in a dude that was not good
sex either so there's a fine line I get
to find that balance there's a oh I
didn't good I didn't tell you guys what
I'm into I'm just
it's gonna be really short the more
helpless I feel yeah and the more I need
to fight back the more turned on I think
oh my god during sex
flashback to every clip on the show I
think Nikki understands me yeah no I do
but so Gina I feel like and and going
off of what Tiferet saying I felt the
opposite where where I felt a
psychological need to please the guy in
the beginning and I did not like
foreplay for me because I felt awkward
like I felt uncomfortable like I had to
pretend to like enjoy it but really just
want to get to the sex part and I think
because I had like these intimacy issues
where I felt weird letting go of control
enough to like let them pleasure me yeah
I needed to be like working for them and
I don't know where that came from but I
feel like like I don't know I'm maturing
enough to when I had really you know
really good sex when once you have like
really good sex I'm like where blows
your mind you're like oh [ __ ] I could
get pleasure too and then that became
more important to me you know get turned
on and to go through the foreplay action
but I do understand you Gina everyone's
idea of foreplay is different where
sometimes I like my hair getting pulled
and like that kind of [ __ ] turns me on
immediately especially if I wasn't
expecting to have sex yeah and like
let's say we're at a restaurant and
someone and then oh well yeah okay leg
or leg grabs my thigh or something like
that I like that [ __ ] I like if we're in
the living room and I thought were
settling down to like just have like a
comfy movie night and then he just
starts like circling like my areolas
[Laughter]
so we're now imagining my brother here
like hearing about him trying but I do
want to touch on because you said you
don't and both of you actually we're
talking about how you don't like the
systemic thing of it before play being
the same each time yeah and I do feel
like we kind of go through the same
motions each time where it's aural like
I first it starts off as heavy making
out and it's very intimate way - in it
and we feel each thing and I think that
really revs up the engines then it goes
to him you know going down on me until I
orgasm and then I go down and hey are
you [ __ ] going play-by-play what
happens when you have second but I'm
saying I mean they're calling it
systemic and yeah I think it's boring
but that we are your secret own of it
changes each time sometimes we're like
[ __ ] it we're going at it and he's using
me and like you know he's slapping me
around and I really like that and then
sometimes I'm like I want to make love
today and so we start romance talking
like like that is that good and it's
very different tone yes your [ __ ]
hits Gina all I see is Steve now I've
mentally blocked it I like to paint a
picture and I just say his toe last five
years so but we're going into you what
you like yeah so I feel like the more
insecure I was as a person the less
foreplay I wanted yeah like an hour full
sexual career I feel like you're pretty
comfortable with your body like I said
the we spa walking around yeah like I
don't have to it's but they're out pink
you have tits you have tits there have a
really nice body your body you don't
baby but you out
when I was at when I was at the spot
with all of you I was just looking right
at your faces don't look down makes it
more awkward the waiter described Gio
during all of JK news you know had to
catch a glimpse was sitting and Gio was
standing so when I turned around it was
just torso and I was like damn okay well
it was a different set of brown I look
up but yeah so I didn't like my body
being touched because I was
uncomfortable with my own body you know
I was very chubby in high school and
like I've had weight issues and I just
didn't really like my body being touched
but yeah the more secure I got with like
where it's like we you know we're for
just all people yeah buggy like let's
just all have a good time is when I
really got into the more that's so true
because I remember when I was younger
and I'd be getting eaten out like I
would I would always have my legs kind
of closed because I'm like no don't like
do it but don't ya because I was so
insecure with my own body where I was
just like don't even look at it I don't
I don't know what it looks like so don't
look it guys I love that [ __ ] I love it
like it like they're like all about it
they're so they're they're [ __ ] happy
to be down there like I know ologists
and [ __ ] for us I'm like let me see
what's going on oh but I do like the
multiple Express packages it's just that
when we have sex and then he finishes he
stays inside and then it kind of like no
I was fine yeah okay and I was I was
like with you now he's fighting Nick and
isolated dick I was vibing but this
[ __ ] over here dragged it in and I
can't drag it back at ya now tell us
about Bart I know so I'm like yeah yay
[ __ ] I can't [ __ ] take this off I
didn't
[Laughter]
no I'm like Gina where I have multiple
packages so I do like the Express but
it's not really an Express so the way it
has to happen my foreplay has to be like
if we're gonna do Express then I want
the text messages I want like oh well
there yeah that's her Express I know so
like a shipping I wanted that you want
me talking about foreplay only though
your DHL messages yeah like I want to
know that you're lusting for me you
can't think of anything else give me the
[ __ ] text be like goddamn I can't
stop thinking about this oh my god when
I see you I want to do this like give me
that and then when I see you it's going
down I don't need anything else like
that's my hope it just goes work Rex ah
because I've been thinking about it for
so long that I'm like second that
already mentally bad yeah is it kind of
an that thing where like you like the
guy kind of like kick starts the engine
but then you start letting your mind go
yeah and like it's like we know exactly
what we want
yes almost like the ultimate form of
like foreplay about the comas like
mental mental the build-up yeah you lick
to my brain and it came whoa that's
healthy okay
Oh [ __ ] you want to get hit with the
[ __ ] vacuum you read me you can't
leave my brain it's hemorrhaging right
now yeah so that's my jam and I'm like
similar to you where if it's now the the
not express package if it's the what did
you call it the luxe deluxe deluxe pack
nobody has my deluxe package everyone's
like 20 minutes tops mine's like an hour
an hour and here you're being shipped by
train yours was ordered on Taobao in
China and it's gonna ship in like two
months or so yeah yeah no I like I like
really like I like it really slow like
even if we're just talking about it like
it if it the slower the [ __ ] better
like if you can drag it out oh [ __ ] I'm
like done like whatever you want to hide
hi maybe smoke some weed or something
you can find it right here forever I
mean I know you don't like weed not
gonna work but if you like smoking weed
and you drag that [ __ ]
you're just like oh my god it makes the
long time I guess better yeah and then I
also like when they come and then they
stop and then they keep going mm-hmm
mm-hmm wait they keep going on yeah yeah
I'm not a lot of guy you like the
complete yeah we're like with Nikki
where it's like cool you came but I
haven't been with that many guys I can
keep going after usually they're like I
need like a [ __ ] 20-minute nap
alright I've had a couple [ __ ] just
like alright ready to go again we yeah
or like I'm just I'm just laying there
like how are you still doing this I
can't come wait no you're during sex
during the second time cuz it's like
already you know what that's why I just
have hour-long sex we don't have to stop
well not stop we don't stop he comes and
then he gets hard again without pulling
out so you know what I am I actually
never told you guys this I call myself a
double shot because um this is really
weird you gave yourself like your
nickname yeah welcome to the double tap
is basically look for third time why are
you the gross carnival guy
[Laughter]
I have this thing where I can okay if I
come I can come again in like 30 seconds
yeah yeah I coming look I come in twos
oh yeah it's really weird so like okay
so I come and then like if you just keep
poking it and I keep playing with myself
come again
yeah and then after that
what happened I come in - I come in -
see I told you this is the shower we're
losing our minds yeah and then after
that it takes me a while but then if I
get to do it again then it's another -
the most amount of times you guys wait
wait wait wait
go boy we still have some foreplay stuff
sorry I've got shoulder hold it okay no
she did it oh we're playing sex I uh
okay all right let's talk about toxic
[Laughter]
talk space online therapy makes taking
care of your mental health more
affordable and convenient than ever
before personally I use it it's
basically an app where you can talk to a
certified therapist after taking a quiz
to tell them what you want to work on
what kind of therapist you want to talk
to you and then they will assign you a
few therapists and you can pick who you
want to talk to so it's awesome because
no matter what you're going through
you're never alone because you always
have someone on your phone that you can
message or voice message or video
message and you can even schedule like
once a month phone calls or like
facetimes and stuff so you guys I'm
actually looking at like see each other
and actually talk and she can talk to
you my therapist is Maria hi I love you
so you can join more than 1 million
people who feel happier with talk space
finding the right therapist doesn't have
to be stressful the talk space matching
process takes your unique preferences
into account to find you someone whose
style and expertise matches your needs
and if you want to switch therapists you
can do that any time so instead of
waiting once a month or once every
couple weeks to sit down and talk to
your therapist you can message them all
day every day they check their phones
twice a day about five days a week and
they'll message you back or the voice
message you back however you like it
so it's always someone there to talk to
you and it's so affordable a month on
talk space cost about the same as one
single sitting face to face hour with
with and with a therapist physically in
front of you so talk
space has more than 5000 licensed
therapists who are experienced in
addressing and the challenges we all
face to match with your perfect
therapist for a fraction of the price of
traditional therapy go to talk space
calm make sure you use the code b-tch to
get sixty five dollars off your first
month and show your support for the show
that's b TCH that talk space calm nice
yeah and also it's time to grow up and
stop buying forty dollar furniture yeah
you want your space to look beautiful
what do you got a do Nikki well I just
remodeled my bedroom and it was very
simple to make a space look beautiful
with a quality piece of furniture I
didn't understand that this was possible
because I used to shop but just like you
know I keep you know like places that
have like very you know no-name particle
boards yeah exactly yeah this is the
most solid piece of furniture I had ever
Ameri into my house it is from article
they make modern furniture with
Scandinavian touches extremely my
aesthetic I actually like a little bit
of bohemian vibe in there too but that
this matches perfectly with my bedroom
and it's such high quality it's very
high like solid solid walnut wood you
would have to try real hard to break
that board on your bed honey
truth real hard with this with this bed
there's fair prices too which is great
because you would look at this bed and
you think it cost a million dollars way
out of your budget no you save up to 30%
over traditional retail prices because
they cut out the middleman they sell
directly to you which keeps the prices
low there's no retail markups fast flat
rate shipping to anywhere in the US and
Canada in two weeks or less and a 30 day
return policy simple returns and
exchanges I received a king-size bed and
it is a beautiful solid wood walnut it's
gorgeous and yes you should look at my
Instagram for pictures because it is so
perfect in the bedroom so article is
offering our listeners $50 off your
first purchase of $100 or more soda
claim visit article comm slash b tch and
the discount will be automatically
applied at check out that's article
calm slash b tch to get $50 off your
first purchase of $100 or more
alright brother bring it back alright
step right up come one come all right
look with the double shot this is a guy
that sells you cursed items yeah okay
well for me personally I somebody that
just wasn't very like sexual earliest
and like I literally I don't know if
I've ever said this on the podcast
before I didn't know how to orgasm until
I was 22
breaking news yeah yeah I didn't I
didn't masturbate I know I tried it one
time and I was like do anything orgasm
it for like five years yeah oh my well
how was your first time then how did you
finally dude it was an aggregate I
literally just I turn on music it was a
dubstep song it was I know exactly what
song it was and I tried it on and I had
been I literally been awake for 24 hours
and I had bought a vibrator at the time
and I just and I had it I'd had it for
awhile and one day I decided I'm gonna
try again yeah and I tried it and like I
was like just having work I don't like
it was really crazy but then you did it
like six more times in the hour ie I
began to use that stick you know it also
I encourage women that you know have
trouble in sex like enjoying it sexually
if you've never gotten yourself off then
you're not going to know when orgasm
feels like you're not gonna like be able
to guide your partner exactly so so yeah
that was you know part of my issue with
sex before but for me foreplay now I
enjoy doing a lot of things I like like
kind of like minor BDSM I love
role-playing
what's minor BDSM explain um like are
they little ropes little fingers
but no like restraints yeah yeah I
didn't really do handcuffs I have like
restraints like under my bed and stuff
does your bed flip over tuck them yeah
you're Casper and those yeah I mean in
its and it's really great it's like you
can kind of like hide them or whatever
but yeah I mean as far as the foreplay
goes yeah tell me what what is this I
have almost a little bit of all of you
because with jeet like I'll do some
texting before and we'll be in the mood
to like bust out the restraints you know
and that's that's part of it and then
you know on top of that there's like a
lot of like oral play a lot of like you
know exploring your partner's body it
goes both ways
will like you know I like role-playing
I'm the type that like I know before
it's gonna happen that I'm gonna put on
an outfit but I'll tell you I'm going to
the bathroom and I'll [ __ ] just come
out and I'm like all right [ __ ] you
know yeah about fit what does this look
like - them I have just have not in my
like wait so he's tied up you're not
tied up no we switch it up okay who
switched it up we are both like Mike the
guy who dress up like that though maybe
maybe we haven't tried it but um yeah
I'll dress up like he's not a big fan of
like latex or like leather but I like it
so sometimes like it's cool like it's
cool that even though he doesn't love it
he loves it I feel sexy in it and I
enjoy it or something my god both stop
speaking to me with that it'll be like
the fake latex it's cheaper but like
leather lingerie like there's this one
like kind of like light blue one that
makes me look like a little [ __ ]
princess he really likes so we're both
very much switches which i think is
awesome
like sometimes I treat him like a piece
of like meat I'm like you're just a
[ __ ] stick you know I do I love doing
dirty talk I do a lot of dirty talk my
partner doesn't isn't always like a
dirty talk type but I it's like my thing
and he likes that I'm enjoying it so
yeah I'd like foreplay will be I love
massages - I'm always down for like a
really I
I do a lot of crazy [ __ ] in foreplay
like foreplay it's like my jam but then
when it come for play an hour um it
depends on what we're doing or how
excited we get like sometimes like we
get really excited if there's a long
text build-up like absolutely and he and
I are both very busy so we really only
see each other maybe three days out of
the week so sometimes there's like a
long wait I would say foreplay could be
anywhere from 20 minutes because
sometimes if it's a massage I'm like
let's do this and it could be an hour
but then for the actual sex I have to be
honest 20 to 30 minutes and I'm good you
know it's better than five minutes it
could be 15 minutes to be honest like
there's enough build-up yeah yeah I like
my Express package don't I get it done
quick but will after that it's like
opening up a Pandora's box because like
it'll be like an hour of foreplay and
they were like Express package then now
we're later Express package like the
foreplay is already done and we can just
roll right into it but like foreplay is
so important because there is a reason
why women have to get wet and men have
to get hard like our bodies are not even
programmed to just go right to sex yeah
yeah you can't just jam it all been
there doesn't feel good yeah in high
school I feel like we tried to just do
that like he was like yo whatever
foreplay whatever we're gonna phone yeah
like didn't work very well
no also it was really tight yes it was
like I can't believe they just tried to
fight I'm so tight yeah mhm yeah I mean
wait you guys don't do a lot like I
didn't I didn't know too much if you
guys do too much experimental stuff like
that or like cuz cuz like I'm I'm not a
big fan of oral like I'm okay with like
giving like oral but I'm not a big fan
of receiving so it kind of just gets
replaced with other things like what
ways is it because you can't achieve
orgasm that way or it's just never felt
good um I think that I'm too in my head
yeah and if think like why do you like
this this is gross like this is
literally judging the body part on the
outside of it like your penis is covered
by skin like I could dude I do not think
like I'm actually like I think like a
while ago I realized like oh my god I
think I have like a crush on this girl
like
I liked her energy I kind of like liked
her I think you both like I'm sorry I
could I could never go down on a girl
like I couldn't do it to me I'm like it
sometimes there's a lesbian
relationships where the girl doesn't go
down the other girl because it's like
that's kind of like the mask yeah so
maybe we should really she doesn't like
being gone I don't like being gone Donna
oh yeah so knit you guys just wouldn't
be fun yeah I was asking because I feel
like I didn't like it either before when
I was 2 in my head because if it didn't
feel good and also I didn't know how to
direct them to make it feel good but the
more I was able to pleasure myself and
know exactly what I like and then I can
communicate it to them and it kind of
opened up this whole new like you just
haven't gotten there yet well I don't
know coming like five years I mean for
me I'm not in my head about like what
because I know he's happy to be there on
there I'm like yeah you like this [ __ ]
you know but it still psychological it's
I used to be like that too because I
like I know how long it takes for me to
orgasm so back then like if he was going
down to me I'm just like oh god I'm
sorry I'm taking so long
are you sure like are you getting tired
like do you want me get you some more
like I was just still beat in my head
now it's just like you're staying down
there I don't got all day baby what are
you going yeah this point I'm just
holding your head down there yeah and
I'm guiding the whole time it's like
yeah faster slower no but everywhere the
world right before this where you get
that exact right that right there
they're at their summit so it comes from
like an insecurity kind of like oh I'm
sorry
yeah and then and and then I had to be
told like dude I like it down here leave
me alone you know so I'm like okay it's
kind of cool and then I learned to be
more selfish and then that's when I'm
just like yeah you stay down there
you're fine yeah I'm saying I really
feel like you can find like for both
both sides of the equation here if you
just find yourself being a little bit
selfish then you both be having a great
time totally yeah and it takes a certain
I feel like it takes a certain level to
get there certain like level of knowing
yourself and knowing your partner in
order to get there but when it does get
there it's so much better
oh also I didn't like oral because I
don't like slide
I'd only drool so if they got come photo
I don't know about it bidam had yeah
yeah you you ever gone down when you're
like there's a better like anything
sugary so you'll produce like a that
really thick I make myself I met like a
Hershey's kiss or something before you
start doing it your mouths gonna get
like real [ __ ] like flatly lady oh
it's gonna get like a really thick
viscosity of like yeah nice extra saliva
and it's gonna be like real [ __ ] I
got I do that I have a lot of spit mmm
I do that bite because I don't want to
do anything with sugarless then it's
gonna go inside me so I don't really
want that on his dick however what I do
is I make myself gag on his dick for a
little bit smart
I knew that makes it all like all saliva
and all this stuff can they like it yeah
they like it too it's like is it too big
like nut [ __ ] I'm trying to get more
spit on but do you like spit down on you
yeah yeah yeah absolutely
if I feel like like trickle down into my
butter me I love it work yeah it really
takes me out of it I love it oh I need
to scoop that up dude it's like my thing
is is if it's like so nasty that like
like it's just [ __ ] nasty it's like
yeah we're [ __ ] into this like you
like me I like you I like all your
bodily fluids
I like your whole body yeah I like your
passion all that and it's just like it
goes so deep you know it's just nasty
there's something about rule though we
get it like I love all your other body
fluids yes kid I've had a guy like spit
in my mouth and hold it shut and tell me
yes always told me oh yeah that's right
Nikki Nikki he held my mouth open that
he held my mouth open spat my mat is on
what is Amanda yucky on Gina until he
told me to swallow that [ __ ] high
even where I can't even play chubby
bunny oh really
no because what like seeing drew or
anyone else drooling or my own draw I
just
dude a guy could literally like hold me
down and make me watch him masturbate
and I'd be like this is [ __ ] Wow but
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm done with yeah
right like I'm not in the mood anymore
but he still is and he'll just like do
it I'm like this is great like honestly
I'd rather you like pull out an extra 60
seconds early and just like do it for a
second so there are times when there's
like random times when I do kind of want
to be dominant expected there are times
when I kind of want to be the dominant
one so what I do is like he's on my bed
I grab a chair I sit there and I'm just
like let me watch and then I just make
him he's like wait watch me do what I'm
like I want you to jack off and I want
to watch yeah okay yeah sometimes guys
will feel a little accent like I've done
this several times where I really have
it but like some news guys will feel
like kind of like nervous I've actually
asked a guy before and he like told me
like no that's weird not as like Caitlin
say this isn't gonna work out yeah I'm
gonna watch you jack off he's out yeah
absolutely yeah someone said no to
something that simple I'd be like
alright you're stuck yeah right square
yeah I feel like that happens the
opposite way for me like if I didn't
orgasm during sex then Steve will like
be okay with watching me mmm
yeah yeah like I've had that and
happened to where I'm just like you just
make out with me or sucking my tits
while I make myself coming I'm good Yeah
right
okay this is really embarrassing and I
feel like I want to share it because I'm
delirious right now yes so one time I
was having sex with this guy and like he
came but I wasn't ready and then he fell
asleep but he fell asleep still inside
of me and so I just kept sleep ya know I
didn't write him you he wanted this
that's called sweet he was like he was
still inside he penetrated consensually
yeah I keep going it's okay right and he
didn't wake up oh he didn't wake I he's
drunk but that's hot but still I didn't
care he was still in there I was like
I'm just gonna move it around and then
it came and I was just like thanks wait
orgasm vaginally or clip that's what I
was going I suppose about
like I can only do it literally it
depends really you've never had a g-spot
I have sex for like five minutes yeah
that is like spray I yeah orgasm
vaginally I didn't like sex to last very
long yeah yeah no um so I kind of in the
same vein of how you guys were saying
with like oral you kind of have to like
guide them I like this I trained this
[ __ ] foot job seriously like he
can get me in ten minutes and like
before I did you do the Traynham
I communicated I was like oh I need this
angle we got like a pillow like I like
and he's communicated to me exactly what
he likes and the thing is y'all like the
first time the first like too tight cuz
it's gonna be like one two or three
times and you have to say like do you
like this do you like this it feels
weird because you think sex is always
supposed to be sexy but once you have
these like communication sessions almost
the sex is [ __ ] insane it's
absolutely insane like literally my dude
can get me probably in five minutes
mm-hmm but in like sometimes he goes
straight for the or guys and I have to
tell them like no that no I don't want
to yet you know but yeah like you can
literally train somebody like the angle
and stuff that they need to hit huh yeah
should trying to go Express well I'll
figure it out oh yeah try this at least
once in your life where you give it a
fair shot because it's game-changing in
my opinion I've had it a few times too
but I'm still what do you know where I'm
like you had no orgasm yeah we're like
in and in your soul but it's it just all
it depends on the experience around it
so if it like took too long and then you
were feeling weird and then oh oh it
happened and you're like okay but then
it was a like it wasn't like that
it was like we're both really into it
and I was just like oh cool this is
coming alright awesome I came then it's
like okay your turn
huh okay question it quick how many of
you guys have had a g-spot orgasm me
well that's imagining okay yeah okay
tell me I'm not crazy in this cuz I've
read a lot of blogs about sex and
everything like when I was like growing
up and it's like I mean you know g-spot
gonna you know it's insane Beauvoir I
think it could twirl or guys it's like a
friend I like it more yeah it's like
it's more powerful more powerful but
it's like a
more like surface-level yeah like this
one is less powerful but it's deeper yes
yeah yeah okay so like I'm not crazy
like I think I quote oral one is
actually like a little yeah favorite
yeah yeah and it like last longer yeah
like you're like yeah yeah Jess I'm
trying to think I mean she's like it's
been without also doing the clitoral one
mm-hmm
because like probably the vaginal one
with no clitoral stimulation at all
those are pretty rare for me maybe I've
had like four or five in my whole life
but usually it's both yeah like I I
prefer both I guess I just act both like
I need him to be [ __ ] me while I'm
playing with my [ __ ] yes how I come cuz
if I'm just doing yeah the [ __ ] thing it
does it takes a while it just a little
bit it's kind of boring for me if she
goes down on me and I orgasm quite
orally because that's good a clitoral
orgasm it's easier for me to come
vaginally so much someone's watching us
I need both especially when they do a
whirl like if it's like they got to do
the oral they gotta have this whole
[ __ ] like they got to know what
they're doing they got to start slow and
then they got to work into it and then
we at some point I need fingers you do
oh I'm like I know we know yeah I need
at least two solid fingers yeah three
Knuckles deep like don't one finger
thing doesn't work the one oh yeah one
fingers you IND well even my OBGYN puts
two finger yeah do I want a pencil dick
no one finger do you want a tampon yeah
fingers in that [ __ ] yeah I also I feel
like you have more dexterity with two
fingers yeah and also for the guys
listening out there taking notes not
once have we mentioned dick size like
this can all my extra [ __ ] dick they
can all hit the g-spot if you have a
correct angle as yes mentioned direct it
so you don't need a big dick you don't
need it has to be more than about an
inch
put it help it needs you can't have my
penis I'm sorry
some people am I still valuable here
good dicks at work
yeah different strokes for different
folks I might not work for you but it
might hit someone a good it good yeah
not mine but someone else's yeah having
a big just gives you like a bigger
surface area so you have like a no you
hire a chance but I don't know like oh
maybe a higher higher change yeah but I
think what the big dick does is it makes
them think oh yeah she's loved it so
they don't even try mute oh my god try
my biggest dick sex was not as good yeah
like to learn performance they literally
the moderate the moderate dicks are the
best idea cuz there's small ones still
I'm kind of like okay it's there but the
moderate ones are good mm-hmm
I noticed I feels like guys with like
like with smaller dicks they lean and
more on the foreplay and then tell yeah
and if they do it's like great they're
better at it yeah yeah and then like
guys with like a more medium-sized dick
like they're kind of 50/50 and like it
could really go pick on the person yeah
and then just for some reason I feel
like sex with big dicks it's like kind
of bad a lot of times it's yeah unless
you're like dating them and you get to
guide them and stuff like that an area
to them at all and to the size you know
like just like all right I got a big day
no because I dated someone once that was
like the biggest I've ever had and he
was really good at going down oh yeah I
mean these are definitely generally yeah
these are a blanket statement I feel
like you are marginalizing big dicks out
there and I just want big dicks are
great testimonials you know they aren't
facts but there's a lot of you know
plenty of cocky kids yeah so try i'll i
can imagine imagine like what you could
do with that big old dick okay give you
actually like try but like settling on
natural talent but if you trained that
big
it could be extreme it could be a
monster that's right if you have a big
dick and you haven't tried your settling
or natural town code free high school
you know your first layer too but once
you start [ __ ] women yeah it's like
game that guide it was like really hot
in high school and never had to develop
a personality yeah like a big dick at 18
he never had to try like learn how to
[ __ ] eat her out like let's I don't
think I care I think most of those guys
like they just they just pump and dump
like a bunch of Copan they don't give a
[ __ ] to learn and you know what good for
them keep pumping and dumping we'll find
the guys that are more fun to have sex
with what you like it oh no no I've had
big dick if it's a bumpin up its kind of
[ __ ] walk - yeah whack what you do is
with big dicks don't know is you can't
always put it all the way in ya know I
like you come barrelling I gotta push
myself yeah you have to put their hand
there so that get yeah yeah all the way
dude or if like the depth of me China
let's just yes 5 inch in a the door 5
inches 4 or 5 inches the G like let's
just say everyone different okay it can
be like three lines six inches okay it
goes up to 9 inches your cervix can be
like wait but I don't know
I wonder you can find out yeah I know it
does but like I'm not having she'll open
if the depth of your vagina is 6 inches
like and if you're just cramming the
whole dick up there her g-spot might be
at 3 yeah yeah or inches like you got a
pull back you spots definitely more
shell what the [ __ ] are you doing in my
lungs dude come back there's no thing I
like about that though probably get east
towne probably yeah
have you guys ever had that happened
where they hit the cervix too much and
it [ __ ] you up for the whole day I had
healed over in bed I haven't oh I have
blood yeah yeah vomit before yeah and
like or it makes you feel like you have
a ton of gas and it hurts everything but
you don't actually have gas you guys
have had that right like an internally
bruised serving exactly I've almost
wanted to puke
like a [ __ ] period cramps yeah yeah
so bad where you're like oh my god the
pain is so strong I want to puke and it
sucks because like the pain for me at
least it goes from like my uterus area
and it makes my butthole feel like it's
contracting sore that it hurts
yikes yeah yeah if my cervix gets hit
that hard yeah I'm out for like almost
like a hold like yeah a whole day that's
a labor
you're like push me in the face but do
not yeah thank you me like oh she didn't
she couldn't walk yeah dad I'm like bro
yeah we're not yeah I've actually lost
interest in a guy because his dick was
stupid yeah sure I'm not gonna deal with
that for life saying can't do it I got a
shovel [ __ ] I can't do it but imagine
your gyno saying like Gina you've got to
start taking smaller do you know I can't
come in here so this [ __ ] up every week
[Laughter]
every week man maybe it hurts cuz you
keep getting its own you think that's
your problem alright guys so in general
what's some like good advice for people
out there that want to try foreplay and
don't know kind of where to start
learn about what you like and
communicate with yourself with yours I
feel like the best way to learn foreplay
is to just like have some sort of
whether it's your first relationship or
whatever like you guys just focus on
that as much as you can even though
you're like 16 17 whatever like spend a
lot of time practicing because that's
really the only way you're gonna know
like that's how you learn how to kiss to
like you have to spend [ __ ] hours
making out when you're younger that's
how you learn so you're not [ __ ] 35
years old and you don't know how to kiss
you just shaved a whole lot of 35 year
old virgin kissers I should be ashamed
they should be a lot of time like we
didn't choose this Gina the N cells are
gonna come kill one person just spend a
lot of time practicing that's always
[ __ ] pump-and-dump like that's when we
need a friend with benefits
dude all I hear Drina purpose I didn't
hear anything just [ __ ] sex all here
is your body is American grade-a sex
thank you all so much for watching and
listening today please if you liked this
episode go rate us on iTunes rate us on
iTunes anyway just give us some 5 stat
rate some big dick rating yeah and then
also thank you to our sponsors article
talk space for article an article you
can go to article calm slash b tch to
get $50 off your first purchase of $100
or more a talk space you can go to talk
space come and use the code b tch to get
sixty five dollars off your first month
and show your support for the show for
newm you can sign up for your trial at
noon that's n oo m.com slash b tch and
for Casper you can get $100 towards
select mattresses by visiting Casper com
slash hey girl and using hey girl at
checkout terms and conditions apply
that's it [ __ ] some foreplay oh yeah
come on y'all